she deserves somebody incredible I kind
of hope it's me Oh a joining us right
now is Prince farming Chris soules and
Chris you know how I fan do we even need
to watch the show now cuz it looks like
you fell in love with Britt right away
what yeah we do something mysterious
happened oh there's some changes that
happen yeah it's so worth watching
so you can't reveal whether you fell in
love with Brad huh I cannot ah
so the champagne was really flowing on
last night's premiere yeah
so why did you keep a tipsy girl Tara
you know I should say drunk she wasn't
even sympathy she was drunk well one
thing to my defense I got to know her
when she wasn't so tipsy when she
earlier on during the night I had a some
one-on-one time with her I got to talk
with her he's very cool girl very very
cool everybody makes mistakes and I'm
assuming after she watched it she made
it regret it maybe tone it down a little
bit I think it's probably a good
assumption to make you know as a
bachelor it does so extremely well they
tease us tremendously so we see that
there's going to be a pregnancy test
this season so are you the baby daddy
they're testing for I can say that no I
am NOT like I had nothing to do with the
pregnancy test and I was not involved in
that so good to have you here thank you
baby when did she make it perfect back
and you find a lot right I do find love
do you hear that
that's great news okay well The Bachelor
airs next Monday on ABC and we're all
set find out what one of the girls you
dismissed to Kimberly she comes back to
actually confront you right it is we're
gonna find out why thanks so much for
letting us go yeah yeah thanks for
having me